is a close Ally of Liz truss as
supporter of hers and someone that's
been linked to the job of Chancellor
within a possible future Liz truss
government he's written a piece for the
mail online in which he said that work's
going on right now to assess all the
options that can help with Rising Energy
prices which will mean that when the new
prime minister comes in whoever that may
be in a couple of weeks time they're
able to hit the ground running and put
help in place in terms of what Liz trust
would do he said that she's already
committed to tax cuts but of course
would look at what more could be done to
help families but has said that it's
entirely reasonable not to detail the
exact shape of that support until she
has all the information to hand so this
trust has of course come under criticism
I think for not outlining more of what
she would do to help directly support
people with Energy prices I think a
clearer indication there that more
support is coming a source in the Rishi
sunak campaign has said that Liz trust
won't be able to deliver support like
that and do tax cuts so someone will end
up being disappointed also criticism
today from one of Rishi sunak's newest
public supporters Michael Gove a former
cabinet minister a high profile front
bench politician for much of the last
decade he has said he'll be supporting
Rishi sunak but has also launched a bit
of a broadside against Liz truss and her
plans for the economy saying that her
plans cut National Insurance and to cut
corporation tax will help big business
and help wealthy high-income earners the
most and that it will do little to help
the poorest in society he also had a bit
of a pop at some people switching
support to Liz truss at this late stage
saying that there was a bandwagon
clattering along Whitehall which people
were now eager to hop aboard and
revealed that he will likely not go back
into government so the end of a front
bench career for this politician that
has been in many top departments for the
last 10 years I think it's undeniable
that whoever makes it into number 10 in
the next two weeks the thing at the top
of their intro will be Energy prices and
cost of living we'll find out the exact
figure of where that new energy cap will
be next Friday in six days time and I
think work will already be going on in
both camps to look at what could be done
in that first month to help people
struggling at the moment with Rising
bills